[Music]
deep in the Scottish Highlands
there's a castle where the faithful
reside
their goal win a quarter of a million
dollars
but hidden amongst them
are three traitors
exciting isn't it
[Music]
you will need the strength of a lion and
the stealth of a fox
[Music]
you might know me from The Bachelor I am
from Survivor Big Brother All-Stars
hello Dad
I know if I was a traitor right now I
would be a wreck you're gonna confront
her when you're saying her name all day
honey I'm looking for every excuse to
get you gone
[Applause]
I think you're a trainer I think you're
a traitor I trusted you
I'm telling you either banish me or
murder me I'm done
close the coffins
in this game the person sitting next to
you may smile and smile and be a villain
I wouldn't pick that outfit so I don't
think I trust your judgment completely
let's talk about death
I can manipulate them because you think
I'm a traitor game faces are awesome
[Music]
hello
traitors amongst you you think do you
know who they are
it's no one
and you thought the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills was bad
[Music]